[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club with over $30,000
in pride on the line 20 international
chess professionals converge in st.
Louis for the 2018 spring chess classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for yet another seasonal
installment of our classic event series
this is the second annual spring chess
classic my name is Ben Simon and I'm
joined with international master by
tally namer
the first time this is gonna be a fun
team oh yeah definitely
high five yeah right and for this
tournament this is the strongest classic
we've had yeah this is the 4th edition
we started early last year and the goal
of these tournaments is to bring you
players that not necessarily are
up-and-coming but aren't the super
grandmasters we see several times a year
for the grand chests or we want to get
more acquainted with the players that
are the 2600 caliber caliber
grandmasters and the like and get to
know them personally and over the board
so let's take a look at the roster in
our top group we call it group a you can
call it the Masters whatever you want to
call it and we have a real international
crowd here by Talia okay so let's see so
on board number one so we have a
position number one again Master Alex
and Ani shook from the United States
then we have Lazaro zone from Cuba same
Shanklin from USA Alexander epital from
Turkey Darius village from Poland
Surya Ganguly from the India version
accordion Jeffrey Zhang yellow Slavs le
book from the USA and romaine Edward
from France six countries represented
truly an international field
those ratings you saw there those are
their feet a ratings coming in the March
supplement and now not only do we have
our masters group a section but we have
the Group B section or the challengers
if you will all right so as you can see
we have
again master a one wonderly end on the
top-rated player in this event actually
is also the youngest one we have
Alexander of the Year from Brazil and
some milk and a lemur Andy from Turkey
which goes by the nickname JJ I
understand those seeds are pronounced as
J's it's like Jamil John a lemur Andy
that's what I heard okay he's a great
guy though a regular here - these kinds
of turnip definitely that we have victim
collapse key from Israel very sketchy on
from a USA player - anchored upon India
action Chandra from USA if Jamie
Stanwyck which goes by Jack from Ukraine
and the gaurav it's from lowers and Erin
grab in ski from USA and interesting to
note Arron Korbin ski there you saw him
there at the bottom he doesn't have a
feed a title and he actually wasn't
originally supposed to be in this
tournament
oh the people who were on our website us
chest champs calm may have noticed that
grandmaster james Tarzan the chess
librarian himself was scheduled to be
here unfortunately he is unable to play
and so we have one of our local
favorites Erin grub in ski the USCF
national master yeah and I think that
actually he has mostly these norms for I
am he just he's the rating and I'm not
100% sure because we just glanced to
that field but he probably could he has
the capability probably yeah with so
many international players yes alright
and this round started each round starts
earlier on of the day we're having an
abbreviated commentary session today's
round started at 1:00 p.m. as it does
most days so we're a few rounds into it
we have one game that's already finished
but let's take a look at the pairings
for our top section it says going on
right now on us chess champs calm and
chess 24
alright so in both number while we have
version a Cobian versus darius peerage
and then ball TT we have again master
our Romain Edward versus Syria Ganguly
again master Alex and issue Chris
playing
against young master Alexander Petrov
and Grandmaster Yara gerbil is playing
versus Geoffrey Zhang and for the game
of the day we picked a game master same
Shanklin against Ken vessel as Arizona
I'm expecting a very big fight USA
versus Cuba oh yes yeah all right and
let's take a look at the games that are
in progress for Group B the five games
that are happening right now eye on
bottom Barrois we have again master
action Chandra versus game master and
rhaegar Ovitz on the board number three
we have Grandmaster Alex and L fear you
versus Grandmaster JJ Hardy again master
prepare - and come upon versus again
madam victim by collapse key and again
master medic catch Ian versus Jake
Steinberg and for the game of the day
Group B we have national master Aaron
Levinsky versus Grandmaster a wonder
Liang and these two have met before a
wonder is actually the champion of the
group e field for the spring chess
classic I'm sure you all remember that
round was last year actually bar came in
he won the top section and a wonder one
group beat so both players are here
let's see if they can defend their
titles and this tournament format it's
pretty simple to understand let's take a
look this is gonna be nine rounds ten
player round robins we have the a in the
B field as we said and the time control
we have 90 minutes for the first 40
moves and then after they make that
first time control each player gets 30
minutes added on to their clock and then
there is a 30 second increment from move
one so if you use your time wisely
you won't flag as they say and vitality
this is this is the time control that
they use in the US Championship and a
lot of big events these rounds could go
a long time yeah definitely I mean it
gives them a lot of time to think about
the chess moves and public each game can
last for five maybe six hours so stay
tuned with us who knows how long we're
gonna be on exactly where we're gonna
bring this baby to you that's for sure
now the last time we were with you it
was with the norm Congress and the
players were fighting
scratching Klein for their norms and
prize money was on the side well this
time the prize fund is significantly
bigger because it's not just a normal
tournament this is a stronger tournament
let's take a look at group A's prizes
and see what the players are gonna try
to take home all right so the window of
the group a will take with himself six
thousand dollars not too bad
second place is gonna take four thousand
dollars then we have the Phil place with
three thousand dollars and then two
thousand dollars for a fourth board a
fourth place and fifth place and 6th
place are going to take $1,500 and
places 1710 are going to leave with a
thousand dollars with a total prize fund
of $22,000 not too bad and Group B isn't
far behind
let's take a look at group B's prize
fund 14 grand up for steak how does it
break down by tally all right so the
winner is gonna take a home full of
thousand dollars the second place is
2500 then we have 2000 for the third
place a fourth place is gonna take
$1,500 place number five we have a
thousand and then we have eight hundred
six hundred four places seven eight and
the last two places are going to take
five hundred dollars so I mean even even
if you take if you can get the last
place you're gonna still get some money
I mean not too bad not a bad deal oh
you're not losing any money coming to
st. Louis oh yeah there are one of these
invitational events well now that we
have all the formalities out of the way
let's take a look at our game of the day
in the top section by tally I know there
is one game in Group B that's over we'll
get to that but let's go with the live
stuff first Sam Shanklin and Lazaro
Brazil all right so let's look at the
games so so far the the game is heating
up we have Brazil playing with black and
Sam check that it was playing with the
white pieces as you can see it's uh it's
pretty messy it's pretty messy so um so
let's see what what how did the game
start
so we have e 4 we have the Sicilian you
know a usually player who people who
want to play for for women for a sharp
position day they choose the Sicilian
night of three is the main move to play
against it obviously and then e six so
we won't be seeing any main lines like
the neither or for the dragon so we're
going to look at the Polson d for the
main line Knight takes d4 in 96 coming
out with his knight Knight e3 so far
it's pretty much the general theory that
we have Queen c7 is being played Black
has some ideas to play Bishop to b4 and
then putting some pressure on this this
c3 Knight f4 wow this this move is very
aggressive taking some extra space on
the Kings side on the other hand this
this move I gotta warn by our viewers
that it is exposing the King sometimes I
mean this this diagonal a7g one so you
wouldn't play this yeah probably not
maybe not in the first round
unless I would come with a very fighting
spirit we don't have one of those words
for this event unfortunately so that's C
so fo was played in the game Knight
takes d4 Queen takes d4 and now a six so
this move a six it's kind of exposing to
the con defense style of an opening
probably in order to prevent white
trying to play Knight to b5 and then
attacking the Queen on c7 a for this
move a fo is intended to prevent black
complain b5 sometimes white is trying to
play a 5 himself so a very interesting
poem game by Sam checkland
do you think maybe it's somehow
connected to his
new book oh it's so funny that you say
that right Ally because I have a book
right next to me Wow this book this is
Sam Jenkins new book I don't know if
you've seen it small steps to giant
improvement mm-hmm
master pong playing chess admittedly
haven't read it yet but Tony rich highly
recommends it mm-hmm and Sam is here
maybe we get to sign a little bit later
oh yeah that's funny I'm getting a copy
for sure yeah so this de-spawn play bye
bye Sam so a four was played B 6
so basically black wants to fianchetto
his Bishop on b7 in addition he prevents
this move e5 not only prevents but if
white is trying to will try to play e5
himself we are going to play b5 so the
idea is that if if we take on a5
ourselves that those those pawns are
going to be doubled so for example like
this it's not not as good not going to
as good for for black so Bishop to e3 is
played attacking this this pawn on be on
b6 rook to b8 Bishop e2 so it's
interesting to see that white is not
Castle long and that castles shot yet
he's still deciding what to do I mean
he's not too late making that decision
yet right right I mean look at blacks
pieces I mean they are still on you know
all of his other pieces did not even
move with Bishop on c8 the ship on is on
their faith but usually in the Sicilian
black that can allow that basically
delaying the development of the pieces
so let's see what happened next
Knight to e7 hmm very interesting square
for the knight at first it looks like
the knight is not going to stand there
and do good but the idea is probably to
put the knight on c6 and then attacking
the Queen on d4 now the problem the
usually we would like to put all night
on on f6 but an iPhone if C is going to
get attacked pretty soon probably
something like e 5
and unfortunately we will have to get it
back so 97 was played castle short by
the way white castles now when black
cannot play Bishop c5 so this diagonal
is a completely safe
so castle 96 Queen to c4 I like that
move it's a well it pins the night maybe
White has some ideas of Knight d5 even
very interesting getting that pawn over
the D file attacking the other night
exactly so basically you know we
recognize the fact that blacks King is
in the center over here on e 8 it will
be interesting to see if white will
succeed in opening up this efile so
Quincy for Bishop to c5 Bishop takes
pawn and now blade decides not to take
the bishop but to play Knight e5
now he takes one c5 okay so black is
attacking this despondent b2 let's see
what happened next
'if I've well so but so by the way
whether what is the point of this move
e5 is that now we call it like a whole
this this the squelen on d6 and now it's
a it's going to be a great outpost
can you see which piece is going to go
there which piece is the best on those
outposts to get to d6 well typically
it's the night right exactly so the
night goes to e4 Knight comes to d6 and
it's like a bone in the throat so let's
see how how black responded to this move
Bishop d7 haha well now if the night is
going to come to you fold probably we
need to exchange it
rogue d1 okay so far so good
c4 Queen g3 attacking the g7 porn castle
okay so finally both players canceled
it's kind of a complicated position as
you can see White has the D file but
black has the B file to attack on so
let's see what happened Bishop f3 Bishop
takes we got some exchange of the
bishops roof takes B - okay so it looks
like black at the product but obviously
white gets the d6 square as we said
before came to h8
interesting move prophylaxis maybe maybe
preventing whites plan something like
like Knight f6 check and the pawn is
pinned yeah I mean if he was on GA he
can't take with the pawn I'm trying to
figure it out myself
h8 move yeah so let's let's just make a
random move let's say black takes you on
c2 so let's try to to check on f6 the
King has to move to h8 and now okay so
now I probably wife has many many
options I mean I can I can even probably
take this pawn on g7 if if I want to do
with a knight but I'm looking for a mate
can I just play something like Queen h4
maybe they cannot take me because of
check and mate very very suspicious for
black I'm sure that there are some some
other moves here probably even the sex
some sacrifices on h7 so definitely if
pretty dangerous for black wood to take
this pollen c2 subject late King h8 and
Queen going back to e1 hmm okay so sin
decides that this queen is not push this
position pretty good on g3 and he moves
the Queen back to e1 I gotta confess I
don't like within chess I don't like
backward moves with the pieces because
he basically just threw away a couple
moves right yeah but let's see so Queen
e1 rook F to be eight so far so far
somehow I like blacks position maybe
slightly better otherwise what has the
ACMA active pieces
but I think that me it might not be
enough so 95 was played King back to g8
and here we are
so this is our position as of now yeah
probably probably it's pretty equal
vehicle but I think that white is the
one who needs to find a solution he
needs to prove that his pawn sacrifice
was valid it's right now we have a pawn
down for Sam but on the other hand Sam
has more time so same as 20 minutes on
the clock and Lazaro has 13 minutes yeah
which move is that by the way so this is
move number 22 and we said that he they
get another half an hour
I can move number 40 but we have 18
moves until move number Foley that's a
little while ago yeah yeah so it's
pretty much like a minute per per move
right they have left here so so yeah
maybe I wonder if we are going to see
some kind of a Queen h4 back to try to
attack this this pawn h7 or maybe some
kind of a rogue h3 attack in this
Despoiler h7 oke stomach moving back to
h4 with the Queen yeah that's a that's a
difficult move to make yes coming
backwards and forward Queen h4 is in an
interesting move actually but I wonder
if I can just play h6 you know we call
this move a window of over basically it
allows the black came to escape
sometimes from back rank mates you call
it a window I call it a window I always
heard it was the loop-de-loops yeah
allowing the King to breathe I see okay
well I guess I guess it's coming from
the Russian language usually there's a
fire fire coming here on the 8th Frank
and so we usually escape from the window
can't argue with that
Vitali I'm looking at another game in
group
a yarrow JIRA book and Jeffrey Jean the
former world junior champion and it
looks like Jeffrey has a an advantage
here let's take a look at that if we can
okay sounds good let's look that's from
the beginning what happened the game so
etho another Sicilian Wow
so we have very aggressive player here's
night of 3d six well in this case we are
going to look at is it an I don't it is
the night off okay
one of the most richest openings ever
played by by men Bishop e2 by the way in
this in this position white tried almost
anything just just to highlight the
board we tried h3 maybe h4 g3 g4 and we
tried f3 f4 Bishop e3 Bishop g5 Bishop
e2 e3 all of those moves we tried all of
them and we still don't know what's the
best what's the best move so this is why
this the system is so complicated so a
600 chose to play the Bishop e2 move
Knight goes to b3 so II five is a it's a
big it's a very committal move because
once black pushes the pawn to e5
basically he creates this outpost on d5
against this this weakness as well as
the d6 pawn is a backward pawn on d6 so
this is kind of the the idea for for
white white white is probably going to
try to attack the d6 pawn or put one of
his knights on on d5 Bishop e7 was
played a castle castle Bishop e3
Bishop e6 a4 so we see this this small a
fall in this game again 97 Queen d2 a5
basically why this getting some space on
the Queen side Bishop to f3 this is
actually pretty interesting moment for
example and white does not want to play
here for although he can it looks like
we are going to capture that the bishop
on only six but in this case what black
and probably just take on the 4 and
basically releasing blacks pieces maybe
something like Knight e5 or 95 and what
kid this isolated colony 4 so this was
not played so Bishop f3 instead h6 nice
to see one you know my opinion about
those small signs you don't like them I
know already like what moves but I mean
to his defense to a yahwah's defense of
it this Knight is it's a it's a bit
passive again so if you can see cannot
go to c5 the C v square is is blocked
d4 also blocked we can leave him on
between to defend the a5 point if you
wanted to but again if it would be up to
me I always say just keep your
development
so obviously the worst piece in the
position in your opinion which what was
the worst piece in the position for
white there's one guy that doesn't do
anything
the fennel thank you thank you for the
visual assistance on f3 that's true the
bishop is not doing much but remember we
have to to get control over the over the
d5 square just in case and so black
sometimes will try to put d5 so we want
to overprotect this the square on d5 now
in my opinion well also we just play
Bishop f3 so well I mean you're right
the bishop here is not doing much but
where would L swill be put it right so
it might be then maybe this the circle
f1 I will just put it somewhere here on
on d1 and you know just to put some more
pressure on the d6 pawn so let's see
what what happens so instead night to c1
it was played let's see what this night
is going to going going for a walk 9 8 7
ok you go backwards I go backwards g3 ok
Knight to d3 Wow everybody is moving the
night backports ok ok so we see some
Queen exchanges rook FD 1 so far the
position is probably pretty equal
nothing much is going on the bishop went
to g2
94 95 I really like this move because
now the night is suddenly over looks all
those squares on h3 night of T check
really the knife is feeling very jumpy
over here c3 was plain okay
look f d8 somehow somehow in this
position I like black more and more form
from major I'd like to compare pieces
sometimes now if you see so white rook
on d1 is probably the best the best in
the position he attacks the d6 pawn
blacks bone is a black stroke is just
defending the d6 bone but look at all
these other pieces I mean we have the
two nights here on e 2 and E 1 not doing
much this Bishop is kind of stuck upon
this pawn on e4 this Lukas has defended
a 5 pawn on the other hand look at
blacks pieces I mean this Knight is
attacking this Bishop has an interesting
potential on this diagonal and the 91 g5
is attacking the e4 pawn so like a
Jefferies position more and more King f8
alright let's activate our King in the
in the endgame 92
check
9c1 not sure what this night is going to
maybe maybe the plan was to put to play
something is to pay something like 93
and 91 and then take up this dis poem if
they respond is this one is a little bit
of behind enemy lines
d5 all right so we have some explosions
in the center pawn takes on d5 Bishop
takes d5 kf1
going back we've got some exchanges came
to e1 and g5 this is a very important
move I think that the planets took maybe
to play g4 so now we are at the position
right now looks like I would definitely
prefer black here I mean all these
pieces are much better I think maybe
black is planning to play g4 and rotate
attacking this this pawn on h2 I don't
know how you defend that to be to be
quite honest I mean you have to bring
your King back to g1 but then we have
some back ranked mates on d1 and look at
the euros time by the way so Yahoo has
only six minutes and Geoffrey has 30
minutes that's that's a big difference
right right exactly a cramped and low on
time now I remember I mean it's it's not
a it's not 5 minutes and 51 seconds
straight up you know there is a 30
second increment you will gain 30
seconds with each move but still a quite
the significant advantage for Geoffrey
Jean right now yeah I would say if it
would be my bet I was just probably g4
and even if white tries to play
something like sometimes Knight e3
attacking this this pawn well I can just
play a 5 and oh boy those pawns are
coming and you know the route can even
swing to h8 and I mean you'll have to
put your knight on f1 to defend this
pawn that's that's not a good sign
the nice but it's denied by the way took
the bishops spots Nitin F will be on f1
and neither guns gonna be on c1 so yeah
so yeah I'll put my money on Jeffrey it
looks like of course he's just joking
we're not cancelling all right so let's
take a look at some Group B action what
do you say bye Talia alright let's look
at the Group B and let's start with our
game of the day which is a wonder the
egg against Aaron grabbin ski so let's
see that's it from the beginning what
happened
it looks pretty pretty equal 9 f3 Knight
f6 g3 okay so we have both opponents
affarin chattering the bishops c4 and
the transpose into the ready English
defense
I've played myself against Aaron a few
times and he actually plays this with
black himself so I think he's supposed
to be familiar with the weaknesses and
strengths of the position
there should be two we see double fairy
shadow and deform so usually in such
positions white is the slight advantage
in my opinion most of the game would
probably white will try to put the rook
on c1 get some pressure on the undersea
porn
the software fades Italy Rossi 8 and
Knight to e5 an interesting idea so
let's see why can't black probably
taking the night will be a little bit
too dangerous for for black because take
rook takes and this this Bishop just a
line in the front of the road but I
cannot see immediately how how can we
get advantage of it
maybe night b5 maybe I because if I take
on d5
they will can just take on d5 and we
probably get two pieces for for a rock
which is which is better so I'm not sure
why like it not take on only five maybe
why can't play something like night to
be five and then take the a7 pot you
know if I compare the eve be pawns it's
not upon with with a pawn
they've even always wins
so it's interesting so black played this
move c6 a little more passive I yeah I
don't like this book so much for black
it's it's really defensive in my opinion
but it also blocks the bishop on d7 but
let's see white 227 okay I wonder why
why he did this you know in chess time
is very important just like in life and
so if we count the day the moves that
white is made with this night he has
made one two three moves with the night
and they only did one move over this
night so technically white is giving up
to four most tempos
so I don't other really like this I
think that another option for white
would be maybe to play something like f4
I would either play a four or maybe try
to bring my nightwear for it would
consolidate my pieces and this would be
my choice
so Quinta is deserving Queen Queen on d3
like the size to fetch at his Bishop
Bishop e3
h5h for nothing much is going on
looks like they're just repeating some
moves and efore uh-huh
well in this with this move what is
trying to probably to to spice up things
but I'm not sure that this will be the
best version for white so basically
after black played this move Bishop to
CC 8 now the bishop wants to come to a 5
so this is probably why Aaron chose to
play this movie 4 but unfortunately
after the exchanges white gets this
isolated pawn on d4 hmm well so far it's
pretty close to equal I would say Knight
to d5 our best blockading pieces
obviously the Knights Knight to g5
Bishop f5 22:27 there are a few
exchanges bishop f8 okay interesting
black decides maybe to put this Bishop
on b4
after this show I like the bishop on g7
so anyway Bishop f88 3 we have a few
exchanges over here
Bishop to see - yeah so now wife what is
carried as some more weaknesses I think
on a3 and b3 look at those bishops they
are just a line to attack them yeah any
like blacks position little bit more be
427 do we have a queen change yes we do
have a queen exchange and Knight to f3
okay so yeah it's pretty equal equal
position I would probably say that black
has a little bit of an advantage again
because of this isolated pawn as you
know in the chess game we have what we
call when we assess the position we have
what we call their pawn chain pawn chain
so if you if we count the pawn change
that White has he has this is one point
chain and the default pawn isn't the
second one there are B 480 so we have
three point chains in this position on
the other hand black has only two point
chains the less pawn chains we have the
better interesting
yeah I've inverted what you might think
yeah so yeah so I think that this this
game is gonna go for a while it kind of
depends I think this this position black
can probably try to make white suffer
for quite a while although I wonder with
has less time he has only eight minutes
aaron has 21 minutes so it kind of
depends I guess what does a want to
think I mean does he want what to draw
just you know to
to make it raw the first game draw black
not so bad or he wants to to beat I mean
after we have the the highest rated
player in that in the tournament playing
as the lowest rated player in a
tournament
yeah the last-minute replacement and
actually I just learned something or was
reminded of something these two competed
against each other just several days ago
on February 28th for the pro chess
league oh my league Wow
and and it a wonder got the best of
Aaron in that encounter now the protests
League your shorter games you know we
have it don't quote me on this but
around like game in 15 stuff like that
it's really made for online it's
exciting stuff you should check it out
protests League calm I believe but yeah
so this is a rematch with a longer time
control just a few days later alright
exciting let's let's see if Aaron takes
up a tunnel image okay so let's see what
other games do we have so we had our
game of the day here action Chandra and
Andre corabeth's in Group E is the first
thing that pops out to me
Oxshott of course hometown kid here in
st. Louis you know if you can still call
him kid the former junior US Champion
and a US Championship regular these days
nice I wonder do you know how like 14 or
1500 wonder is 14 or 15 probably at the
moment yes some rock shot is a little
bit older okay okay interesting
lots of young guys we have here May and
it's just in a month okay so let's let's
look at the game accident as playing
white versus and rhaegar of it's okay so
we have the period defense some people
call it birds so life long debate yeah
Oh an e5 and interesting variation so
immediately black offers to for white to
go into an end game that's you won't
have a night of three 937 and Bishop c4
yeah so basically basically here white
has the option to take the pawn pawn
takes exchange the Queen's and try to
play this position which is probably
slightly better for white because black
is losing his castle but eventually
black usually manages to play a move
like c6 and hide his King on c7 just not
not too bad so action decides to keep
their the Queen's on the board and
playing Knight f3 Knight bTW seven
bishops before that's probably the
easiest development ever I put in
putting more of my 2 nights out and
bishop on c4 and now it plays a four
okay
maybe this is the movement of the day a
for I've seen it on almost all the games
so far so c6 rookie 1a v h3 this ship
goes back hmmm I wonder I wonder if the
bishop could have stayed on this
diagonal I really like him on this data
maybe Bishop to beat Lee so that would
be another option for white kind of
depends on your taste Bishop d3 937 ft 7
and sorry to interrupt here by Talia
Jeffrey jean has won his game against
the ROG book so we'll be talking to him
shortly all right sounds good actually
actually let's let's see how how he won
this game that's the best the game that
we were discussing right with the yeah
let's see so let's go let's go a few
moves bear so I think that we stopped in
this position after okay for and he did
play g4 yeah and 93 there exactly as we
predicted and then f5 yeah an h4 ok well
that's a huge gamble I mean but what
what what else to do with white if white
if white plays I mean that's it's really
difficult to find any moves for for
white actually can you move any of these
pieces probably the night only three but
everything else gets stuck so h4 may be
a last resort
pawn takes on h4 by the way this is what
we call in hunt passant in chess and
rotate it took to h4 tries to get that
the truck that's pawn king f7
and another pawn v6 and that's very much
a the game game is over I guess why just
has known no moves interesting will be
very interesting to discuss this with
Jeffrey today indeed indeed it will be
will have here in just a moment where
were we at with the last game here I
just want to go back so that just for a
second here battalion let's see
so under Gulliver's against Akshay
Chandra yes alright let's let's just
jump to the end position we have a time
pressure by the way ten minutes so we're
in time pressure right now six-minute
minutes to under as far as I count the
pieces what is just a pawn up right is
we have this healthy pollen c2 I mean
it's a long way for white to win because
the overall idea in such positions is to
somehow to create a passed pawn right
now White has no passed pawns but on the
other hand black also has this very weak
pawn on d6 yeah so I am for probably
white what has good chance to to decide
this game
so so yeah so what can we so what can do
I do here let's think about it
roof d6 is an option Queen d6 is an
option how do we get to this this pawn
would be six maybe route d7 rugby b7 and
then exchange exchange the rooks and
then we can win the the pawn on d6
another idea maybe to try to exchange
the Queen's in this position and then
get to a much favorable endgame I wonder
if I can somehow move my knight
somewhere maybe 92 94 so yeah so I
always see that white is is a bit better
here okay so let's let's look let's look
at the one of our first decisive games
of the day today at this moment I have
get message official welcome to our
studio congratulations for for the win
thank you nice so did you prepare a lot
fo for the for this game yesterday Yara
I prepared a bit but the wine that he
selected caught me off guard okay yeah
so we we saw that you guys play the
Sicilian I was just telling that the
night of us probably one of the sharpest
openings that we have today and then
Bishop e2 a five-night bTW this is
pretty much all Tilley probably yeah
Bishop e7 castle castle Bishop e3 Bishop
e6 this is all standard although white
sometimes can Castle long right instead
of guessing short I'm not sure usually
you
they counselors sure in this okay so
Bishop to e6 and then a four I assume
you felt pretty comfortable to play this
with black so far yes but actually after
Queen d2 with Brooks the a5 I had a big
thing because okay normal move maybe
something like Queen c7 but I was kind
of concerned about if he plays let's say
rook f d1 and then it's not easy for me
to play because he has very good control
of d5
I mean Queens to 6f3 leads to nothing
right and eventually he just wants to
play like rook a c1 in 95 and
yeah I guess that's one of the
weaknesses in this position right this
is this know in 75 and also d6 might be
hanging at some point okay so yeah sure
I wasn't sure so that's why I went for
rook e8 because just kind of a way
and I guess the idea is that once he
plays 95 maybe real if I will open okay
makes sense so he decided to play here
Bishop f3 yeah here I was a little bit
surprised at that f3 maybe makes more
sense just honestly right cuz [ __ ]
bonito is quite good because it stops
any ideas for example and controlling c4
right it looks like a little bit weird I
think that his idea maybe I was too
faint shadow the bishop but when she did
not work so well obviously if he tries
to play here f4 is too aggressive right
I think yeah here maybe I'll just take
probably 95 no but okay so after Bishop
f3 I played h6 kind of preparing the
idea in the game and he also decided to
I was actually discussing we were
looking at this position alive and and I
said I really don't like going with my
pieces backwards
so sometimes it's good I mean but this
is the smooth 91 was very you probably
think it was a little bit he should have
maybe started with rook F d1 and right
you see what happens right there look
everyone just much more natural to me
and I assume it will play something like
maybe Queen c7 here or maybe yes okay so
it's a bit night c1 was played and then
yeah nice and I think was timely because
this Dartford Bishop restraint is
usually favorable for me and
then I have controlled the c5 square
which I can maybe put something there
later right and well you're thinking
about f5 at some point oh that's
probably too dangerous
yeah it's probably too much because his
[ __ ] mother of three is doing nothing
so I don't see why I don't exactly okay
so g3 looking the bishop left a bit now
I think maybe that maybe that's the move
oh that got you the point
no g3 and wicking in the white squares
I'm not sure maybe okay I was maybe it
helps play rook e1 yeah it definitely we
can have three but what probably he
criticized later is after g3 Bishop g5
93 your Hara decided 98 probably the
confucian move 96 is quite strong and
yeah this is the movie criticized
because this basically allowed me to
improve my posture up here and then now
this GT move really started to
really weakened his position because dr.
Cates takes takes takes and he started
experiencing these problems which sure
which you mentioned right and the Queen
exchange was pretty good for you right
because now the screen is not there to
attack the d6 pawn yes see two and a
five or a week or now without the
Queen's help right yeah it's it's
probably a very difficult for white to
find a plan here I mean what there's no
plan because I think just this a five
and a four he has to keep an eye on that
and he simply can't do anything yeah
silent suffering night e to explain and
then G for that's nice you get you got
some space here or study this night
looks pretty beautiful here
and I think after this move Knight
II won that was mentioning that I really
like blacks pieces I mean the position
was looks pretty pretty bad for for
white just those night only to anyone in
I don't much maybe the critical ISM yeah
so after King f8 he has to try to do
something I was looking at f4 maybe pink
but f4 let's see I take an emphasis on
big stakes
94-95
I mean instead of the night of three
probably ninety fours right you're just
reading a pawn correct 95 and I think 94
95 five years then three for you now I
can even just win the a five politics
everyone thinks I mean fun right yeah so
this one didn't work
let's try to go back he could also but
you know but you know what I mean this
disposition might have been much better
than what he got in the game because at
least somehow looks like his bishop is
more activities or open divine yes but
she's working but unfortunately I think
I can just start really have fun right
but after okay the other thing it tries
maybe night see to immediately right
maybe to put an item t5 somehow yeah if
you can get a 93 maybe it's more
reasonable but maybe the problem is this
should be through right yeah this pin is
quite annoying and now I think it's the
weekly thing is Rick see one out of
three might be an issue
so Rick you too probably I was trying to
see if night of three let's anything
right yeah well it's good enough I mean
I have three cakes take just 91 cakes
takes be farming very nice actually it's
just already lonely squared yeah you
know he has to take and then then you
take D file at least 55
they might even these strong symbol
underneath yeah those some subject
nights here yeah yeah it's very
difficult to play to find a plan here
for white okay so we played Rudy to
instead kingi seven nice inclusion of
the king yes and now it's just hard fun
to make any they check now this
and d5 was an important push I will stay
take take
and then you didn't want to take the
rock right I thought um taking with the
bishop saves one time six
ya know just watching for making change
right that wasn't probably that's the h2
pawn and then get obviously Rudy one I
was coming so after the he has to defend
yeah you know G fire was a pretty good
move
I think after G for well you expecting
this move you H for I knew I thought was
a move but I mean I was pretty sure it
shouldn't be good right okay maybe if he
waits perhaps like let's say he just
plays Knight of 193 for the rest of his
moves I wasn't sure exactly how to
proceed because I can maybe put my
Klingon g5 but I'm never sure about f4
because then he can play 92 and maybe
gets control before so I guess there was
some work to do if he just waited here
yeah well maybe maybe after waiting this
knife maybe someone play this Eve Eve II
for definitely 95 made sense lots lots
and lots of you didn't like Rudy v and
taking this really fine yeah many
options but yeah so h4 was a gambler
takes I guess King f7 was pretty good
move because now he can you can't take
HD that for oh okay
so if Ruth takes h3 there before and
then we this check doesn't work right
yeah then I can hit the real connect
that changes six okay so now you had to
waste time good night
the affordable for was not necessary but
okay okay so he has to pretty much just
move their hook on the H file much but
then a five that April is rolling mmm
okay very nice very very nice game you
know Jeffrey who you play next tomorrow
I have black again against Dario it's
weird
alright well I thank you so much for
joining us say good luck in you next
game tomorrow and we are going to go to
for some commercials I'll see you back
when we come back question on Twitter
from dem s I should not have pronounced
that that was a bit of a champion
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like pa3 is an illegal move
here because white advances pong two
squares not one but it's a little
something we call autosome and you can
do that but you have to do it instantly
you can't wait for a move I can't say
play King in seven Kim G - and I'll try
because four against Lawrence and now
he's going to play something against me
which we discussed at length during the
course of my stay
yeah he told me this is accident g5 this
was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think we finally know who
Lawrence this is not how she has works
certainly would be much much more fun in
chess actually work like this don't
think it does
oh maybe it does well that's me
regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of it my quality
of life has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
[Music]
there's a weekend vacation on one tank
trip in a nearby city you won't wanna
skip
[Music]
and welcome back to the 2018 spring
chess classic coverage of round number
one
my name is Ben Simon I'm here with
international master of Italian aimer
and we just heard from Jeffrey Zhang the
young Grandmaster from Texas who has
earned the tournament's first victory so
we'll see how far he can go in the event
that was very impressive win it was yeah
and we actually have some other
happenings over the board right now
anything about to be clinched here I'm
still looking at the game of the day for
group a we have Lazaro Brazil versus Sam
Jenkins and it's reading as a draw right
now it is but look at the pawn structure
kind of strange I don't know who is
better it's a yeah it's the this night
of a fire was just played by by black
usually we don't like to put the Knights
on the edge of the board but I guess say
you had no choice you had to defend the
c4 pawn I mean we see with cities those
pause the age porn so white has a passer
what we call a pass one an age for black
technically does not have a passer and
also this this night on on d6 is quite
annoying and yeah although the copies oh
oh actually it looks like they are great
for a draw
you didn't believe me no okay I mean
look sometimes those results those AGT
boards they put the Kings on the wrong
squares in the center that's how you
activate and put them on the white
squares for white wins but have black
squares black ones sometimes that messes
up you know yeah only this I wanted them
to keep fighting like this build yeah
it's over
Sam Shanklin of course longtime US
Championship competitor have has his new
book that he will have for sale here in
st. Louis if you're in the Midwest why
not come and see some of these players
over the next nine days there's no rest
day we're going straight through nine
days rounds one through nine round-robin
Turner
yeah definitely and they by the way it's
pretty exhausting to go without any rest
days I mean usually in the sink filled
carb and World Championship even then
they get a rest day but in this one
there is no rest no resting yeah and and
a lot of these tournaments you you don't
see rest days
my theory is there's only so many days
to play chess in the calendar year
there's no time to rest
exactly I know but it's tough you know
non-stop chess right so the so let's see
the games of the day
Group B we have so that's some throws
group a we have Kobe and against various
looks like it's gonna end up in the draw
as well although they are both in time
pressure but clinching in to move number
forty so it looks pretty pretty equal
although black has better chances
because of the bishop obviously versus
the knight but once those aprons and be
pawns will be exchanged it's probably
gonna be just a draw what do we have
left only shook and keep it off and we
haven't looked at that yet right on the
sugar and a bit of hmm this is the
Alexander match yes okay let's trick
yourself a former US Champion
from before the st. Louis chess club
days right so it looks like right now
that if I count the pieces
correctly so wife has a pawn up and
actually why is it two pawns up right
and he's under a check by the rook and
the King has to move somewhere so I
probably don't want to move it to d3
because then black can just get me
capture the pawn on a3 with another
check but where should I go
well maybe I can move backwards maybe
came to see one or rook to c2
let's look we have some some moves
coming King to DT was was actually
played in the game
I don't think you have you may not have
the right line here yeah let's see maybe
I maybe I should have fresh my board
yeah let's do this alright now we have
the right line parcel lots of lots of
things happen in the past few moments
let's go back a little bit you know I
think I need to refresh my board so
rooks it to was played in this in this
position that that look make makes
perfect sense
Ruth takes it to Ruth tasty to still
white as a two points up so black can
recapture the pawn yeah what Knight
takes on d4 Bishop takes d4 Realty is d4
and it is white to move and now looks
like on the cameras only shook still
nobody's on the board you know you know
why is that right I mean is anybody we
even play there yeah you know why
because they just pass move number 40
yes we're gonna stay here for a while
longer just like that 30 minutes each
clunks on to the clock exactly so hes a
blatte so that's it so it is so far it's
white to move and well I have to move my
king somewhere probably King III or King
City will be White's choices and I would
say white has pretty good chances to win
this endgame I mean I'm a healthy pull
up and yeah I just need to bring my king
probably came to seat Lee because their
DN distinct c3 has been played has been
failed yes so yeah so the idea is just
to stop pushing the pawns rolling this
this apon together with the support of
the king and to be honest I don't I
don't see how black can do anything
because the king on h7 is so far behind
it even if he does try somehow to come
over and stop this pawn well we had this
we have this frequency to I mean he's
just completely cutting out the King and
I know I have lots of arrows in the
position but I guess I just I like
arrows
so what the most I've seen don't okay
challenge accepted I'll try to make more
arrows so yeah so it looks like to me
that white is going to to win this game
how did that happen that's let's look at
the at the opening so we have d4 okay g6
niger Bishop g7 okay interesting
variation to be honest aya I'm not quite
familiar with this setup usually what
blood does here is that he plays
something like Knight of 6 and it goes
into the Kings India but black decides
to play this movie 6 instead hmm very
interesting in my opinion usually black
does not want to put his paws like this
I mean like checkers I guess but ok
let's see this maybe it's a novelty
Knight of three and then d5 okay
interesting
he 5 and the biggest problem again and
in this position is that black is going
to suffer from those dark squares in my
opinion so we had 96 Bishop e2 h6
castle castle if some developing moves
Bishop d3 putting the bishop on e4
it looks like white got lots of pressure
probably is going to going to put his
rooks on D or the D file and on the C
file here we go
now black did exchange the Queen's I put
a knight on d5 so actually this
disposition does not look so bad for
black now it was kind of equal because
this night on Don dd5 on this outpost
how do I move him out of there very
strong night roses six was played
the books are coming in with some some
kind of a maneuvers with the ropes and
now Roxy - 9 f 5 9 2 D 3 ok
h 5 was played rogue c4
so we have a few exchanges here how to
say who's well it's probably kind of
equal because white has this weakness on
d4 and black has this weakness would be
five so looks pretty equal so let's say
let's see what happened
d4 okay so black is trying to play for a
win
Brooksie for all it takes eight three
point six eight three g5 this this one
was a little bit strange to me obviously
white cannot take on g5 because of
ninety eighty four and we have this
nasty for coming in however however well
after g5 I don't have to take this point
and this point might might be still
hanging so Ruth a safe for Ruth to be
three King to d2 roof to be one I stuff
like this position more and more for
white and then eventually white takes
another point
let's see what's going on right now it
just goes yes so still King City as you
can see I epitope is not it does not
look so happy that's there's another
happy stance so he's tried to figure out
probably how do i how do I save this
position maybe something like well I
have to try to attack this this pawn on
only five with maybe rookie 4 but then Y
can probably just sacrifice the point
where I have to sacrifice the Panda is
no way for me to defend the pawn so
maybe you're going to see something like
the line maybe night King b3 or let's
just put the rock behind the pond we
always want to put the rocks behind the
pond by the way in the chest I'm games
especially to support the pond so now if
tanks then a for if it tries to blockade
the problem is just rolling together
with the King and this King again is
just too far I think is gonna be a
decisive result in this one yeah I'd say
so
it's looking pretty good for ownership
and that's the board 5 game in Group A
the only other game going right now in
Group A is a cobia in spirits
let's look at this at this position
interesting this is a action Chandler
against Andre Gorger over Oh Group E yes
indeed this is definitely probably not
going to be a draw I mean well right now
white probably just is going to snap the
truck from the board and lots of Queen
to Queens M games they actually end up
in a draw because of Perpetual checks
but in this case I mean Greg probably
needs to take enough to White has what
is coupons up and as long as white
maintains his control over this diagonal
not allowing black to make any perpetual
checks
weena for Quincy one and so on I think
White has pretty good chances especially
if we succeed in exchanging that could
the Queen somehow let's see if I can
exchange Quinn somehow right now I don't
see an option to exchange the Queen's
but maybe just playing something like
Queen c7 or maybe c4 c4 c4 looks looks
pretty good to me or trying to check the
king so yeah I think that that white is
in a driver seat in other decisive
results yeah
actually Chandler he had a pawn up so
I'd see what happened he'd probably do a
few sacrifices over there so we stopped
in this position right they drove to be
8th route e6 yeah
uh-huh so queen a fall and salad that
the Queen has left the Kings side and
now rope takes he six very nice
sacrifice check and Knight to e5 my g5
force looks pretty good but by the way
the threat here after Knight e5 so let's
say black just makes a random in a
smothered mate here yes yes good job yes
yes so let's just show of yours let's
say I just make a random of a queen bee
one and then we have negative 7 King g8
the night h6 very good we have a double
check after night to h6 the King has to
go to h8 and then we proceed with a very
beautiful Queen sacrifice Queen g8 by
wrapping him up like a sweater oh yeah
and finally that counts to f7 that would
be a beautiful ending well obviously
black saw that coming and he played h6
to prevent that 9th to f7 check
well the nice okay I thought I was
saying the Knights not sure he wants to
go there right he just you know stops
for a break yeah check here so we have a
few we have a few moves
which being repeated in the game night
xh7 check on the five
and eventually why did take on
why do you take on on be a 10 plate see
for actually maybe I need to refresh my
board but yeah actually here what's
still wide to move after King age 7 I
wonder what what action is calculating
here to take the rook or not to take the
room this is the question I say take the
rook alright well we're gonna interview
Sam Shanklin you a few moments very
happy to do that
yes the man with a new book great us
championship competitor sorry if that
was a little bit of a 180 for you but we
just got word that he's here you know
yeah yeah by the way Akopian and spirits
have drawn their game over in Group A so
that leaves only one game left in Group
A but we're looking at a groupie game
here right now so yeah so it looks like
another game is finished and good be the
game of the day no it's actually still
going a 1 on the yang against Aaron
globe in ski so we have material balance
who is trying to win here why has this
dangerous past policy 6 but on the other
hand he also has a weakness on 8 3 now
Aaron has 40 minutes versus 16 that's
and that's a pretty big advantage I
would say but so far it's looks pretty
equal and probably maybe even end in a
draw
so far okay so what else do we have we
have oh that's that looks looking like
an exciting game Wow
both Kings are naked no pawns no
defenses what what what happened here
victim mihailovski versus priyadarshan
let's see what have informed from the
opening c4 okay so we have the English
defense d5 of g3 and $0.90 III and the
other variation will be 96 Bishop e3
interesting Knight to f3 c5 Queen fo and
Queen c7 Castle actually I like I like
White's position here but as a white
guides some kind of a advantage
like that lots of counterplay let's look
at the end position Knight takes e4 okay
so we reach the 40 moves everybody got
half an hour it looks like black is
better well first of all black is just a
pawn up for some reason the white king
does not look so safe probably black has
some back has some chances to move the
the King and maybe ruku g8 okay so now
I'm excited to welcome and Sam your game
was pretty exciting oh really
I wasn't sure it felt like it sort of
was equal throughout I was looking for
funny variations every move I was trying
to get a 5 n or 96 so I didn't quite
make it work at the beginning I thought
I should be better and at the end I
thought I should be better but in the
middle I may have been worse and right
when I thought I should be playing for
it when he offered me a draw I started
thinking like wait I'm not better at all
so I made the draw and I love to fight
another day so yeah I actually I think
that the last the position when you
finish the game was even then pretty
interesting yeah it was probably pretty
equal but just the pawn structure very
imbalance but you could have played for
instance might be 395 when all the pawns
to start getting traded I have to take
on c4 he takes on a 4 I get that all the
pawns just start going so I didn't
really think I had do you think you
could have improved any worse
yeah I'm sure I must have remembered I
didn't prepare for time on earth at all
today I was expecting some kind of
Berlin or something
and yeah I check this out form of I
remembered after a four I thought what
was better because I thought 94 and a
six was pretty principled for black but
after a four I loved whites position
because he can't get b5 so easy at all
but once he gets to b6 I thought I can
pressure his Queen side pawns and I just
couldn't remember how to set my pieces
so because I felt like with these pawns
on if he's playing repeated and she
cannot play Bishop d7 because Queen b6
it's going to be hard for him to
organize those Quinten but somehow he
did it very easily and I think yeah so
as fo is not considered the most fashion
align it isn't that the Bishop Bishop e3
Queen f3 is the most fashionable
nowadays but play with 2680 player who's
playing the time on of and I've been
playing time on it with black recently
so he must have seen that unknown that
I'm gonna be well versed in their
critical lines it and if I had known
that I'm out of was coming maybe I would
have prepared queen of three but right
this I thought was I think I got a very
pleasant position but somehow things
went wrong and here this is 97 and I may
be a Quincy for was a mistake I don't
know castle seems pretty normal
yeah maybe even low castle well I don't
think it changes very much actually if
he plays 96 all the same I think his
pieces still go to the exact same
squares Queens here I have to worry
about about the four part hanging with
check and a lot of these lines with
Bishop c5 so it's here on Bishop c5 okay
it could be similar to the game I don't
know and he could even play BC for
example or take the check of first so it
might be a bit dangerous for the kingdom
thing yeah and she's got the e5 square
I would prefer black there I mean I
thought Castle short made a lot of sense
I mean I'm you don't play a for it to go
so long and Sicilian too often right so
after after Castle short knight c6 maybe
I should have played Queen due to but I
thought that if I'm not pressuring the
d6 pawn and he can comfortably develop
with Bishop e7 I don't think I should be
better I mean blacks pieces make perfect
sense so Quincy for would felt
consistent and I was very happy with
White's position after takes Knight I
five quid d3 I was expecting him to take
with the Queen on c5 just look with the
pawn and I thought after e5 they should
just be better if rugby 294 should just
be made
think there's any way around that right
I calculated one funny line Castle
Knight g5 g 6 so this should be seven
yeah that was the rule takes I mean you
don't even need to look too far to
realize this is crushing but I've
because if 96 is just going to die and
if you're right if he castles I get 95
g6 coin h3 h5 and I just chopped it off
and I think black is just done for very
nice so this wasn't wildly difficult
calculation but I was optimistic enough
to hope something like this would come
but of course he played Bishop e7 which
is a much better move not allowing 94
and I thought I should be better somehow
but I just didn't I couldn't figure out
how I mean work 81 felt consistence can
you can you try maybe to exchange those
bishops maybe thank you
the problem was bitter enough through
hit places before and I can't put my
queen anywhere she really wants to go
because really she wants to go to g3
right and I want it's a sort of I could
play Queen III here but for instance if
he takes on f3 now and I play rook f3 I
he can play Queen b6 and my dad d6 kind
of like in the game it's not that
impressive if I don't have Queens on the
board with Queens I'm just going to made
him but without I mean I thought the
endgame black is completely fine and if
he plays Queen takes of three he can
even play d5 and I thought that like
that's not doing so badly right okay so
I thought that rook d1 made a lot of
sense improving another piece but c4 is
very strong and I don't know maybe a
queen g3 was too ambitious but looks
those good to me just wanna make him
struggling to find a way forward because
there's about three I mean I I felt like
I should be just you know trying this
position did you consider maybe playing
f5 thought you can always just take it
and I never really understood what I was
accomplishing like he plays rook a e8
and rookie six or something and I just
thought there's no way I'm ever doing
anything special here right this is sort
of the appeal of the time in August upon
his on d7 so whenever f5 you can always
just take it and not worry because at
the pawn on d6 you often don't simply
lose it but something like this I
thought was completely fine for black
steel he's not only five looks like
awkward yes but the same time rookie six
Ricky
it's all coming right now maybe i-5 was
a better try than what I did I thought
it was most principle to try to bring my
night into the attack
so recompute 294 and then catch it was a
really nasty move right so he can't he
can't take on let's have at least a draw
I mean I was calculating so for example
if he takes on tsutsu I can make a draw
right away with a very funny line I can
go native six King h8 Queen g7 take four
FG 3 and if King age 65 is just make on
g4 I did this in shades and Queen quit
g7 is just a draw after up to three I
think unless I missed something
computer is laughing at me because I
thought here I can look oh I see
wreckage 3 you can take on g2 ripchu
ripchu 7 this time h6 still looks pretty
dangerous for Beth we got an extra quid
I didn't I don't know yeah but I had
plenty of other options
apart from this and I was not even if
this was a dry wasn't planning on making
it I thought I could go Queen h4 h4 is
what we looked at yesterday became and
h6 I was thinking I could play like rook
H 3 and 4 per Queen g5 and there were
all sorts of problems black was facing
so I just thought to iron out some of
the variations but I felt I'm not
risking anything of course so but King
h8 was quite a nice move and then a
Queen e1 I wasn't thrilled with but
didn't see what else to do I know that's
actually that was my comment doing the
game was like no I didn't like I didn't
hate when the pieces of the backwards
but at the same time it actually makes a
lot of sense because the Queen will not
stay on it he won forever I want to get
in rook h3 first and then make him burn
another tempo to get there up to H 1 and
then I have attacking chances for sure
right and I also felt that if worst
comes to worst I'm not even doing so
badly in this position even pawn down
like so for example after Queen e1 but I
thought he should have I thought he was
gonna take on c2 here actually mmm I'm
done after rook h3 Queens to 6 I think I
have to just make a draw with rook h7 I
didn't I thought it was very clean b7
Queens to 6 something like that I
thought I had to take it yeah
yeah makes sense I mean h7 is somehow
hanging off 295 can you for right so so
he didn't know but he pled for a win
which I was actually quite happy to seek
so I didn't think he should be better
here I was hoping to continue the game
so 95 and then kingi it was another
pretty nice smooth and I was trying a
lot of things to make work here the real
thing I wanted to play off 5 so badly
but I just couldn't make it work FIV
plays like h6 for example and I was
checking you know Knight f7 king f7 f e6
and rook d6 but he gets away I write
these do you have any like ideas of 97
here but and if he takes it I think it's
just a draw because I play rook h3 kingi
eights Queen h4 King f8 and this King is
sort of running to say if they have to
play Queen g5 be pleased came back to g8
and I think this is just a dress
everybody I was sort of worried about
equalizing this I wasn't sure this might
be a draw to okay
I was I was planning Queen g5 instead of
cornet right okay and then he has to
play King Jia to avoid ricochet tonight
gotcha
yes it looks believe with equal yeah but
so then he when he played Queen b6 and
rook p1 it was clear he's playing for a
one but I will you'll you will actually
up in time for most of the game right
yeah well I caught him a little bit by
surprise in the opening and then I think
I played a little faster at a couple of
critical moments so at the end it's
possible my time advantage helps me
escape with a draw when I was maybe a
bit worse but here I still thought it
can't be that bad I mean Knight g5 and
like takes takes Queen B 1 rip duan i
didn't think i should be worse here i
mean but the critical line was take take
and then f6 instead of King f8 as he
played and then just I was considering
this and just hang everything on the
Kings side go for the safe on and just
try to
Queen it like I was calculating a funny
line there EF 6gf 694 f5 I don't think I
can give check on f6 because King g7 and
then reflect yourself in Turk d8 and
didn't see how to get my night out the
other hand how does it get you nice o
knight c6 to b8 for example I couldn't
figure out how to get my night out but
maybe there if there's a way than I
should have gone for this or well I
didn't have the opportunity because he
played differently but I didn't see how
to get the night out yeah that's a good
time just maybe I maybe I can play rogue
d6 um Knight f6 or something weird like
that but I couldn't figure it out during
again yeah so I was going to play Knight
c5 instead and then so yeah well I've 6
take take Knights e94 a five-night c5
and I'm going to take a bunch of pawns
but he plays rugby two and well that's
his sleep on me very very fast and I I
wasn't totally sure about all this I
thought I should be fine but it's yeah
it looks pretty equal because it looks
like you guys exchange all the pawns and
yeah but I I can't stop the C pawn I
couldn't figure out how to stop it at
least I can play rook c1 which is a very
sad move I was planning c3 actually yeah
see this is okay under x2 to h4 rooks to
357 I thought should be okay yeah I mean
maybe you have some facial checks then
yeah I hope so I mean if he plays like
rookie 3 here it's still a little tough
but too much trouble making a draw here
yeah see seven and I do something okay
so King f8 was play instead yeah and I
racks here I actually thought I could be
better which was probably foolish so
King me 794 and then here yes to stuff
95 so Trixie it's and then I put this
monster so stupid move rook d6 I just
completely blundered that after knight
c6 I cannot play Knight c5 because of 95
by the colitis five and then actually
after 96 it's actually extremely
annoying I have to deal with that six
like right away
and I think actually I mean it's
probably still very close to equal but I
was for it I could be a more time how
did the rook on d6 is in this place yeah
yeah well as soon as he played knight c6
at first I was confused he just let me
play Knight see five months ago he's a
doctor kit now a lousy position but six
so I wouldn't be averse to a draw but if
you played officer up - and if you play
Knight back - if I would not have played
back to do so yeah of course even though
I wouldn't be averse to a draw here I
just hope you wouldn't find something
better but f6 is normal I guess 96 I was
expecting ricocheted not rugby it but it
probably doesn't change that much
mm-hmm so take take and I think this c3
is here I was actually a little
optimistic so Brooke h8 g 390 and at
first here I thought I'm just better and
then he played night at 5 and offered a
draw at first I was just gonna like slap
his hand away and say come on let's go
but then I realized what I actually have
absolutely nothing to do if he plays a 5
next move I'm permanently stuck for the
rest of the game and I can never go
anywhere and he can just shuffle rook g8
ricocheted as long as he wants so the
only way for me to continue is a 5 and
then he could play for example Knight B
3 and after Knight to c4 rook c8 just
everything gets exchanged very quickly
and so f5 is aja can I can I move and if
I move the knight backwards then he can
play d5 may be all right for here yeah
yeah after D thought I thought I'm gonna
be worse because I was looking at this
position I thought okay maybe you have
some chances with that past fall and h4z
for this like for example let's say I
play King g2 and he plays some stupid
maverick h5 then I think I will be
better after f5 but with the rook being
this active I just
but maybe I can try and find myself yeah
that's what I said here I would be
better after a five right
but given that black is about to play a
five on me I had to do it right away and
then I think 93 is just a dress so I
didn't really see much point to
continuing the game okay exciting game
is especially with all the pawn
structures and I know that you just came
up with a new book yeah I did those
small steps to giant improvement I'm
actually doing a book signing here in
st. Louis right after the tournament on
March 15th it's not yet available
publicly so if you want a copy in
advance you can come to the signing all
right perfect I'm sure I will never get
one all right well my bone structures
well thank you for joining us who are
you playing next I think a Cobian I call
good okay you're gonna be black so you
have that fight yeah why does usually
kind of been the boss of the board
whenever we've played so you know that's
sort of favors I'm in this regard but I
should be okay okay well thank you so
much for for joining us and yeah we're
gonna look for that for that book yep
and good luck in your estimate
tournament thanks thank you
quick commercial break and please stay
tuned with us because we have some more
games going on a moment comes in chess
when you need to test yourself at a
different level chess 24 premium offers
the tools that you need to reach your
maximum potential from hundreds of
interactive video lessons to becoming
part of the chess 24 community you can
analyze with friends or coach your
students live you get twenty four by
seven coverage of chess news and events
access to premium analysis and
commentary and the chance to interact
with grandmasters and other top players
and coaches get it bashed from the best
and even challenge them to a battle be
the best chess player you can be it's
time to level up your game with just 24
Premium Membership I'm Mike Matheny
whether you play chess for fun or want
to boost your child's academic
performance come visit the Chess Club
and scholastic Center of st. Louis right
here in the chest capital of the u.s.
from a welcoming diverse environment to
a Scholastic outreach program now in
over 100 schools our Center across from
the World Chess Hall of Fame the Central
West End has it all so whether you've
played for years or never before we
invite you to experience all chess has
to offer
be surprised be intrigued be delighted
the world chess Hall of Fame in st.
Louis is nothing you'd expect and
everything you love three galleries
highlight the history culture and
creativity behind the game explore chess
in ways you never imagined it's a
one-of-a-kind cultural institution where
rare artifacts and world-class art play
together the world chess Hall of Fame
mind art experience
[Music]
you can fly to Venice
[Music]
or Paris or even Copenhagen
you could fly all over the world but why
when you just come to st. Louis your
trip begins at explore st. Louis calm
[Music]
professional Twitter from dem s I should
not have pronounced that that was a bit
of a champion
for those of you who are new to chess it
might look like ba3 is an illegal move
here because white advances pawn to
square is not one but it still is
something we call autosome and you can
do that but you have to do it instantly
you can't wait for a move I gotta say
play King in 17 g2 and I'll try because
[Music]
[Music]
all played four against Lawrence and now
he's going to play something against me
which we discussed the playing during
the course of my stay
yeah he told me this is excellent g5
this was what I was kind of hoping for
because now I think he might as well
know who Lawrence this is not how it
works
certainly would be much much more fun if
chess actually work like this I don't
think it does well maybe it does well
that's me regretting what I just said
how did I get from there to here is a
little bit beyond me and what's worse I
will never hear the end of it my quality
of life has just gone downhill
tremendously because I'm actually
sharing the office with the guy
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get it bashed
from the best and even challenge them to
a battle be the best chess player you
can be it's time to level up your game
with just 24 Premium Membership
[Music]
we're back here in st. Louis for the
2018 spring chess classic its coverage
of round number one my name is Ben Simon
and I'm here with international master
of Italian aimer and we are just having
tons of fun oh yeah a blast I mean we
have so many decisive game so they
already two oh two and three decisive
games and still some people some rounds
are not finished so let's look at some
some other games that we have here let's
see so we have still Erin convinced kids
playing it with a wonder liang we have
three games going in group b we only
have one left in group a and it looks
like owner shook is just about to wrap
it up with alexander Eva Tov yeah let's
look at that at the ad game yeah we
already mentioned that game before that
this de-spawn on on a5 is a very strong
passed pawn and while it just is just a
pawn up and the king is just gonna walk
together with the pawn and he's not
acquitted that's it Quinta with it
there's no way to stop yeah it's yeah
even yeah pretty much
there's no way so I'm sure that
Alexander epitope is trying to use all
his time to try to figure out if there's
any chance for for draw here but I think
it's going to be decisive pretty soon
another board that has the apon marching
up a running of the board wildly as
Chandra and Gorda bits yeah and we
mentioned that before we had there the
Queen's endgame this might in just any
moment here right chief oh yeah just the
only question is how do we how do we
Queen this this guy just oh yes just a
few checks maybe something like Queen e5
let's try this H takes G has been played
oh it was worth it okay so H takes G
King takes okay the only thing I need to
find out is how do I check the King and
get my pawn rolling it's a good question
okay I have so many checks actually so
almost any check I guess I just check on
these seven here and doesn't any matter
where they could where the King moves
because on each one of those King moves
I always have some kind of a check and
then that just pulled upon on on a eight
yes so it looks like pretty decisive for
for white let's see let's a fudge the
board for a moment
Oh King h4 was played wow you did not
take on g4 you know what I'm thinking
about I think that Andres is playing for
for some kind of a stalemate some tricks
yeah so it's tricky what kind of tricks
will it be looking at well for example
let me make this move Queen f4 let's see
if you can find the best move for black
here and I'm gonna give you a hint the
King cannot go anywhere oh well sac the
Queen
yes exactly very good Queen takes g2 and
we're in a stalemate that's a nice
little trick yeah
the only question is is actually gonna
play Queen f4 I don't think so I mean he
has so many options you know how to win
probably you know checks would secure
the win
probably Oh actually we can just you
know to get the king in check on h4 and
control the aah square I mean I can just
check on d8 and if you take on g4
probably no probably just Queen and
there is no stalemate anymore my friend
that's that's been much hey this part
we're gonna be over in pretty soon let's
see what's going on in the and the game
of the day
Ruby curve in ski and a wonder yes I was
wondering if Aaron K if L can beat that
one though maybe has some chances for
norm maybe even the GMR open the game is
over
action Andra with the win just as
predicted yes very good game great start
for him you know Oxshott really wants to
turn his fortunes around he had kind of
a lackluster event the last time he
played here in st. Louis just a few
weeks ago so this is a good start for
him definitely nice the white pieces
making undergarments very strong player
what do we have left
Victor McAuliffe ski versus Playa - and
come upon a PD he's that when he goes by
yeah PD I never knew that yeah I guess
he's like really professional right here
I don't know that enough that much to
call him yeah we used to go through the
same school so we're kind of a very good
friends Webster yes he's - he's still
there I already graduated so yeah so
looks like let's see now
looks like that the tables have turned
we left somewhere when when both of the
kings were exposed
somewhere in this position okay and then
black decided to exchange the Queen's
that is very unusual so there so when we
left this position I was I was
mentioning that the black spot will be
to to move the King to the the H bar and
then bring the other rows to the G file
so King Queen to check I wonder why he
didn't move well if King h8 and maybe
Bishop default check but can I just pay
king hh7 how does how does why defend
against Ruchi 8 I think it's gonna be
extremely difficult for Y to defend
against this
I guess piano is cool you can call it
yeah it's very interesting
so like decided to exchange the Queens
now
[Music]
the night goes back to have six and
suddenly wine got some some chances for
a draw hmm that's why I called luck
while still still black as a pawn up but
this pawn on d6 is pretty strong I mean
the knight cannot cannot live there his
post because d7 is coming with a pretty
nasty fork this this Bishop is attacking
the a5 pawn and you have to the other
side I'm having some difficulties to
find a plan for full black I mean if I
play a four maybe I can just start
marching with my king
another model binding this knight on f6
so really yeah I mean the obviously
Becca's gonna bring his king as well I
think but I think that this game is
going to be going on for a while yeah it
could be that's for sure and we meant we
may be off the air by the time it's done
black mica Levski is really doing his
best to not get forked this is something
we know a lot about here at the st.
Louis chess club for more information
subscribe to our YouTube channel yeah
anything if he does you give him a fork
no no if you if you don't get forked you
get the force oh I see yeah it just
comes out of the kitchen there's really
no fun going into and you use those
fancy ones so I'd the metal ones no not
the plastic ones well yeah they're metal
but I don't you know it's nothing
special
okay yeah I mean it's really special
okay excellent so what else do we what
we have going on except Chandra will be
joining us here in just a few other
sites to talk about his victory in Group
B against Andre corabeth's and right now
you know live standing Zack shot is in
the lead with the rounds not over yet
and Griffin ski is also looking really
good against a wonder
let's see I wanted to see if yeah we
have some some moves has been made in
the Alexander match Group A yeah and as
we said the King just moved all over to
c7 and tough decisions I mean the rock
has to go to a eight and in this case
probably we could just play a rock a two
to swing a rope over here sacrificing
this pony five you know maybe maybe
black no his only chance is somehow two
seconds is rope for this pawn and then
somehow get get those points so
something like a six and then the
problem is that on an on the road takes
a seven I can take the King and now I
don't make progress okay well let's try
the h3 take
actually which one to take
yeah eventually wife is probably just
going to win this pretty easily the King
can come March up or march down or I can
start pushing my pawn yeah I put up I
believe that Alexander is gonna win and
the ownership one
let's see okay we have said we have some
moves have been made
oh wonder Liang okay looks like look at
that see porn that's that simple is that
this pastor is gonna is he going to quit
well it's black to move and if King goes
to d7 the only move that allows black to
prevent for Queen Nia that Bishop takes
a six still put the equal position
materially but I wonder if if Aaron's
gonna get some chances for the other dog
I saw him just for a second there on the
camera he's looking pretty chill he's
out of the frame now but yeah look look
at that time I mean I thought that Erin
is is a pretty fast player and I think
that psychologically gets lots of
players nervous I mean in just two
minutes and that's after the time
control so this is move number 48 or we
see both the players I wonder is really
really in the tank right now yeah by the
way enemies also going through my school
he's also a friend of mine and he wants
to be an engineer yeah
Aaron Aaron's a cool guy I first talked
with Aaron in one of the classic events
last year I was doing recap videos and
you know these players it's so great
with you you can really get them to open
up and talk about their lives because
it's tough you never know otherwise yeah
a lot of these players are really quiet
so in an interview capacity is really
fun to really hear their stories yeah
and they know I remember I wonder when I
just came here to the United States I
remember very young and we play the game
and then I actually won back then he was
like 1700 after that after three years
we played in the spice Cup he said to us
and we draw
and now he's a good master yeah so
pretty much in a wonder I wonder how
many years like in six years or five
years he became a grandmaster so that's
to me it's pretty incredible you know I
have lots of students especially people
who know retired in the 50s and 60s and
they have come to me that is asked me if
can I still become a grandmaster
well yes everybody can become a bad man
so you just put you know blood and sweat
lots of hard work and can you get to it
and yeah that's that's pretty amazing I
mean it granted when you're older it's
infinitely harder yet still possible
because you weren't brought up
necessarily with that Ches environment
yeah I mean return about akshar Chandra
in five years five years I think he went
from 1,500 to 2,500 so man that's that's
crazy
yes I would like to another secret yeah
what are they eating for breakfast yeah
I was looking at Chandra calm I think is
his website I was there the other day
just came close to revealing the secret
not quite there might save that for a
book or something you know all right yes
exciting stuff
let's see do we have any moves in that
game No so still looking at both of them
all quite
it is errands errands move so black did
make a move and I think Blackie seven
played King seven oh wow oh wait a
second can I just for what the Queen
nice to take and probably he needs to
let this has happened has happened okay
interesting you know what's gonna happen
Aaron will have to prove us see if we
can check me through the night and
vision you'll see it's gonna it's gonna
happen that's going going through there
well there are still some some points to
be exchanged but I think that's a one
dose best best bet it's tough to do not
everyone can do it Grandmaster Akopian
has done a class here at the Chess Club
nothing but how to check rate with a
bishop at night so it's it's an art
admittedly I couldn't do it yeah
actually I only wants in my life I had
to do it in rated game yes here in st.
Louis Chess Club oh man and I've done it
but to be honest I've before that I
never learned that technique exactly so
luckily for me my opponent is helped me
a bit but since then I learned since I
know I know the W but yes so they kind
of stumbled into it you didn't have to
do the long form yeah oh yeah and I had
more time so I know that sometimes when
we used to practice at school we used to
put I used to even for my students I
give something is one minute go that's
so one minute versus one minute can you
do it that's there's a back that's on
the on stake holder over there yeah
that's that's gotta be nerve-wracking
yeah so so good for him so b4 has been
played by a wonder that's fresh my board
before okay so yes obviously a black
tries to find some kind of a counter
play he's not lost yet he has those two
passed pawns but that's that's a huge
upset though if he's going to lose I
mean the top chess player and then that
that
Sulaiman losing through the lowest-rated
one absolutely yeah and no doubt about
it this is gonna be a huge game-changer
just here in the first round it could
end up being one that is yeah and who
knows I mean he a so we said that Aaron
was not supposed to play and he just
joined just a few days notice right and
he piecing it together now I heard my
comer talking about it yeah my comer was
on the phone with other representatives
of the club and he said you know James
Tarjan he can't make it
but Aaron Burr prince qi's here he's gay
good should we do it and everyone was
like okay let's do it
yeah so that's that's how we get it done
in it Verbinski may have been here
actually for protest League business I'm
not quite sure but now that I'm thinking
about it maybe he was so maybe that's
why he was around the chess campus yeah
okay so moves are being made here on the
board so let's see b4 was played and
then 91 Knights b1 okay Bishop c4 and
then the knight took the a bishop and
then on captured back oh no wait hold on
did if we took on on a3 then the one see
that beautiful check wait you're right
about that
look that appears to be the case but
unfortunately for us
Khan takes on a three and then f4 was
played a to Bishop c3
that's that's not what I was talking
about look at look at Aaron's time even
though he has 22 minutes but he plebe
litters out his his moves it puts so
much pressure on the opponent and I know
that I have played with it and a few
times and that's that puts you under
pressure even my games we were in time
pressure so yeah so I think that going
going pretty well for him the only thing
I can say about this position is that
why probably needs to activate his king
so as long as he can and bring his king
over then he's gonna just pick up those
pawns a six a two and I don't even see a
way for black to to him to get any
counter play just like this Bishop on c3
I mean I'm just gonna leave him here
black probably needs to play a 5 which
was played in the game and because he
wants to release the King from the
phoniness pawn of 6 I'm just gonna sort
of March my king over I mean can I just
play oh I can also play something like
Bishop to e5 and the idea here is that I
want to cut the king of of coming here
so even if the king count goes to d8 I'm
going to play Bishop e7 and look at look
at all those pears this one is is taking
this one is taking I mean that's it here
comes here comes the king the Kings yeah
King f2
so let's see what was was playing
against so f5 was played while King f2
was played the King d6 I will assume
we're gonna see King III mm-hmm indeed
probably Kings he fires Olympic thing
that looks right yes
again where is the king going well even
if you try to put the King on b5 I have
a check on d7 I can even play Bishop d7
now and the problem is that now I want
to play Bishop ae8 and put some pressure
on those points so he will have to
probably be with the bishop let's see I
saw a king move I would say it was
probably King to d2
yeah I would assume that white probably
going to win this position let's look at
some some other games that we have still
going on let's go to let's see if
Nisha's finished this game in this
position yeah that's pretty much what we
put it predicted and white keep probably
going to promote the Queen rook takes
King takes that's all on the board yeah
from the e5 so basically black tries to
create a passport let's see if he's in
time take take in c6
and now the problem is that if you play
here III or then King d5 and that's
that's pretty much it
making g3 probably I can just play king
e for and that's it I'm going to pick up
the pawns and but other than that I
don't think that black has any any other
chance but good try go try and we have
one more game going in Group B victim
McAuliffe ski versus PD and then that is
of course besides the Griffin ski a
wonder game there are two games left in
Group E but yeah this is one that we
haven't seen too much recently yeah so
it looks like a while new who got
exchanged this this the d6 one is still
very dangerous that's that's unclear to
me to be honest I don't I don't know
what what we did the result because well
probably the King has to move somewhere
that's a king g6 here
maybe I can try to play Ruby one maybe
swing over and take this this pawn on d5
but then rookie five is one account so
that's that's not going to be so good I
would say white needs to start push his
King but if I try to play King G - maybe
rookie it - let's see what happens if if
they exchange rose in the case of the
exchange rules well what I like about
blacks position is that his pawns are
all on light squares which is pretty
good in this kind of a endgame
because they say and they have agreed to
a draw and draw yes as we say a
friendship one not sure of their friends
but they might be now best friends yes
my comer they're the expert placement of
the Kings as we said one on white when
I'm black that triggers the DDT system
those computerised boards to collect
call to draw so if you haven't ever seen
those boards are pretty cool by the way
okay use them for all the big
tournaments that leaves one game left
vitaliy yes let's see sir Aaron Levinsky
the match the match of the day
Group B match of the day let's see so so
we have white to move and yeah I have a
feeling that that Aaron is a rival seats
he can definitely win this game
let's see how do we do it so I cannot
think this point if I've obviously
because then black is going to promote
to a one I think that we have some some
moves have been made so let me try to
refresh my board okay so this is the
most recent position a4 was played okay
so now we just need to start picking up
those pawns but I guess it's not so easy
how do we get this this Bishop to pick
up those pawns looks like this this
Bishop on f7 is pretty strong covering
all of this diagonal interesting
so what needs to happen here to stop
this advance on the a file for black
well so black doesn't does not really
want to play a T because I can just take
the King luckily my my bishop is
defending the a1 square but the problem
is white is how to make progress so that
definitely a tuple is a criminal in the
positional we somehow we have to arrest
it but how how do how do we do it
I mean usually we would come up from
this diagonal and take they take the
pawn but in this case we this diagonal
is just too short and if we try to get
it to this one well the bishop is
defending it so I don't really see an
easy way to do it let's try to make some
moves not about just King a3 I just want
to get this this this pawn on on a4
let's say black is going to defend it
with Bishop e3
hmm okay well that that might be that
might be the problem for black so black
he put his all his pawns on white on
light squares so now you know when we
played Bishop to b3 to defend both of
this a four and A two pawns his flank is
being undefended so now I'm thinking
about how can I get this bishop to eh
now that might not be the easy task but
we have time right we have time sure
well yeah I mean there's been a couple
moves made but we can investing it a
little bit always someone somehow like
this that's a what happened in the game
fresh my board King c4 was played
and then Bishop f6 King before
and I think that's where we are
yeah I'm not not as easy as I thought I
mean definitely a wonder is putting
aaron to some work it's not a it's not
an either bishop endgame but still not
not that not that over so what can we do
probably Bishop e7 check let's try to
check the King I cannot go to c4 because
then I can I am going to lose my
pollinate too so King to be five and
then maybe now Bishop to d3 check and we
start pushing the the King away it's
cause it's gonna take a while because
now the problem is that I cannot move my
king form B to because I have to guard
this this a1 square interesting maybe
something like Bishop to c5
well luckily we have we have an
increment here so wife can play forever
yeah you may remember like eight minutes
or ago a wonder had two minutes left
right any time
it's how chess works you know we want
time to work for us exactly yeah
maybe it wasn't a place for long time
okay let's see um do we have any other
games left that sort of gup-a is the
well yeah Group A is completely finished
Alexander owner shook has defeated Alex
heap at oh yeah
guys I said that that was a this a pawn
that that pastor was just so strong
right and vitality since we had group a
completely wrapped up I understand we
have the standings all ready to go no
it's just the first round but let's take
a look anyway two decisive games today
what is your take on this okay so I
think that so we have two leaders today
Jeffrey Zhang and on this you played
very good games outplayed their
opponents in the in the end games so
they're with one point and then we have
a bunch of people with their withdraws
brew zone Sam
Darius Syria inversion and Romain
half-point and Alexander epitope and
yellow stars over on the bottom but it's
just the first round right still many
fights ahead eight rounds to go we're
gonna have one round every day the
rounds themselves start exactly at 1:00
p.m. Central
but we're on the air at 3:30 and the
last two rounds we'll get to that later
on they do start earlier even though
there are no playoffs slated to be in
this tournament so if there's a tie for
first at the end that's just how it is
they're going to share the prize money
they'll be cope champions this is
actually the first
time that the classics have not had a
playoff stipulation in the contract
however we've only ever needed it once
it was the Fall Classic I do believe
Jared Meyer and Cher book oh yes so
we've only near that once hopefully we
won't need it again because we're not
going to get it but the last two rounds
will start a little bit earlier now it's
a little bit theoretical right now but
assuming Aaron wins let's take a look at
the standings in Group B now I can't say
it enough
Verbinski has not won the game yet and
he still has some work to do but this is
assuming he defeats a wonder your take
on this fatality yeah I mean it would be
a huge upset for for a wonder
so immediately Aaron Jett would jump to
the top of the rankings here with a
point
together with action Chandra and again
we have lots of people who drew the
games Alex out of the year AJ Jim Moran
the victim may have ski miss Kitka Gian
PD and we have Jack
Ashton book and yeah but again it's just
the first it looks like actually the
results will be similar to the acre of
whoa look at Aaron's rating that's
astronomic I know it's when he seems
very suspicious right there yeah it's a
performance that's how it's yeah so if
he beats a wonder then he will be
playing like 2600 yes like a 26:13 okay
well we are waiting for the last game to
wrap up before we wrap up the show we
kind of tell you about some great
upcoming tournaments here at the st.
Louis chess club that you can watch
online first of all we have the
candidates tournament this is the eighth
player double round-robin event and we
will have abbreviated coverage of this
starting
about ten days or so and then after that
our homegrown
tournament the big one it's like
Christmas here because we have the US
Chess Championship April 17th to the
30th two weeks of nothing but fun and
the top five players are the five
Americans in Group A of this tournament
are going to be in the u.s. championship
as well is as well as a wonderland in
Group B so that's going to be great the
best in the u.s. joined by Wesley so
Fabiano Cara Juana and Hikaru Nakamura
who will be the 2018 US Champion you can
watch it at us chess champs calm and you
know that's gonna be a lot of fun by
Talia hopefully you're around to catch
some of this action I don't know
I hope so well I'm from st. Louis I'm
gonna catch it anyway good
wonderful wonderful and after the US
Championship the grand chest tour
continues and especially here in st.
Louis this tournament we all fell in
love with last year the st. Louis rapid
and blitz August ninth of the 16th at
Grantchester org and while the
participants have yet to be confirmed
you will see the very best players in
the world give it their all in rapid and
blitz events all rated by the universal
rating system of course and four grand
chest tour prizes and points this year
it's before our other signature event of
course I'm talking about the sixth
annual Sinquefield cup August 16th to
the 29th it's back to back with the
rapid and blitz the cup is the classical
event on the grand chest tour and now
the only one that will be exclusively
classical after the news that the London
chess classic will now act as a final
this year for the grand chess tour but
let's not look past the 2018 Sinquefield
Cup that's gonna be a lot of fun
once again the players have yet to be
confirmed but it will be the best in the
world you know it the fourth annual
grand chest or the sixth annual
Sinquefield Cup Wow very exciting stuff
I think maybe this club has maybe
even the most rudiments ever than any
other club maybe you guys broke the
record we don't have time to look and
investigate if we broke the record cause
we're too busy running tournament I know
but we broke some record that's for sure
definitely well I sent to assist conceal
the capital of chess because of this
Chess Club I mean that's that's that's
quite amazing indeed well let's uh this
game we have going on group in ski and a
wonder I don't know that we'll see it to
its conclusion updates on that well as
you can see we do have some some changes
in the position and I wonder I wonder I
wonder if it was been benefits white or
black as you can see in black succeeded
in pushing both of his pawns to 80 and a
two and how am I gonna get my king out
of a1 when the king kinda prison by
those prison criminals
so he's hostage anyway so let's try to
find out Aaron's plan I think it's
somebody just went to wrong that's a
little back a little bit because it was
so much more winning before I mean he
promoted to Queen over here and now
before he played night to be one okay
Bishop c4 this was all good I think this
was this was the moment that he started
to to play with the skiing very fast
which is very logical very natural in
the in the endgame he will just wants to
be the king but hey what about maybe
first of all blocking the opponent's
just cutting of the opponent's king and
if you would just stay here Bishop e5
and black tries to play King d8 and
Bishop e7 well that's it I don't see any
way for for black to make any progress
and this this way my king can easily
come to b2 and
and well I think that then Oh actually
maybe my king can just go around and go
to a five I could probably take the a
six pawn
there's just no contemplate so I think
this this was this was a little bit of a
mess so after after brothels is king in
to be two he played with the king yeah
he allowed the black to play a three
there was this amazing end game played
by Magnus Carlsen versus Nakamura
recently just a few weeks ago it was a
rook and pawn versus Queen and game and
Magnus was trying to make a draw with a
rook and pawn and apparently he also had
the a pawn and the April and started on
I think it was 8th a six or a five and
once he pushed upon all the way to a3
then this is where it became a
theoretical draw so one day I wonder if
I can still win here because what what
is my what is my plan maybe to put a
black into some kind of a Sutra let's
let's try to make some some moves I
think I'll finish the board just in case
okay so black just make it make some
some waiting moves so he just moves the
bishops around around and he just waits
this Bishop ooh
the problem for white is that if he
plays Bishop e7 going for this a
three-point or it allows the black King
to sneak in it's a sneaky move if I take
the King III how do we stop this King
way I have to play well that's it I mean
the Kings will come to F - Oh F - hmm
and if that happens I think a waddle
might have some chances yes suddenly it
doesn't look too clear yeah so he
probably so you cannot do that he needs
to keep the the black King away so he
just needs to move the bishop to D clay
and I think that I don't see I don't see
a clear plan for for white I think we
have to stop counting the moves we
probably know about the 50 move roll so
without any capture or an important pond
also the last poem was let's see I mean
we still will have quite a while to go
but you haven't raised a good point I
think it was a five on 50 pardon me it
wasn't probably the 83 exactly so now
King a1 and also 63 and now we are at
move number 72 I know actually no we are
not in 72 yet we're at 69 so obviously
it's just six moves after but I think
that that's that is what black blacks
goal is just to just to move the bishop
all the time back and back and forth and
I don't see
I mean let me try to move the my vision
to a four that that would be my instinct
to put the bishop on the a but obviously
if I play the Bishop to a four well I
can just bring my bishop back to f7 and
hmm
yeah it looks like there's a lot of
bishop shuffling going on here exactly
and so if the game will be drawn we are
going to be having only one leader in
the action Chandra at one point well I'm
not a superstitious fellow hopefully we
didn't jinx mr. Gribbon ski here no
point okay so we have okay so we have
some some moves that we made a Bishop e7
check so Aaron tries to play for the win
and we said that this maneuver is gonna
be a bit dangerous as well for for white
because it allows the black King to come
to c3 and basically now he's gonna swing
his king over - f - probably just zigzag
something like this this is how his
Queen egg is king and take on g3 I don't
think that white is actually risking
anything because the worst-case scenario
even if the even if the King comes and
takes the GT pawn we can always just
rest our bishop on g3 and just move
around there is no way that they can win
this
so we see that lots of moves have been
made
let's not flash the board
yeah so this is exactly what happened
the king is coming and to take the GT
pawn and small and more like a draw and
this is a final game right yeah this is
it in either field the last game of the
day
yeah I think we've got to be thinking
more along the lines of a draw
right here yeah but you know even if
even if Aaron gets a draw when you get a
draw against the highest rated player in
the in the field that's not too bad I
mean yes you Valley with white pieces
well that's that's pretty good yeah
definitely in a comment just ready why
is it's probably worth a few points like
those that they have taken a few pieces
yeah the bishop is taken she's six
hmm okay so Bishop takes on g6 King
takes g3 believe this happened okay so
lots of exchanges the problem for white
that is that he cannot lose both of the
pawns he needs to keep at least one of
them to try to play for him because two
bishops versus one bishop is I was the
same as just one bishop so Robin ski is
thinking probably which point am I
which one am i rescuing because one of
them is falling down Oh baby is thinking
about which one to take the f5 point of
the h5 point
so let's make let's try to speculate if
white takes on f5 looks like white took
on h5 on h5 ok
I assume black needs to take on h4 just
in case but obviously I can also
probably take on f4 but just not to
create some past pawns for white not to
give him any unnecessary chances
how'd it take here the problem is that
now this Bishop is attacked and the king
wants to come to GeForce I have to keep
my bishop on d1 but then King g3 will be
coming Bishop to d6
and
how do I want to activate my king well
the good news for error is that he might
be able to take out his King
but the problem is is that let's say I
make some random move so if I try to
advance or making somewhere black can
all always sacrifice on a1 so something
like this take the key takes it for this
would be just a drop yeah they were
seeing arrows now is it does not look so
happy it doesn't look like he did
all right well you know it's a we've to
results probably a draw though at this
point I think it's fair to say probably
yes so taissa forgive us on our
standings that we showed earlier may not
be exactly correct but we will see
tomorrow whenever we're right back here
at the same time in the same place us
chess champs calm
remember the round itself starts at 1:00
p.m. so you can watch it on chess 24 and
on us chess champs calm and hashtag
spring chess classic to share your views
and thoughts on Twitter vitality final
thoughts on the day yeah very exciting
very exciting round I mean we've seen
some some wins some some draws and I
think that the players are going to come
up with some you know some some new
ideas tomorrow don't forget that many of
them are coming from abroad probably
they have some some jet lag still and
they might have just wanted to start
with a draw I think the more you see
some action
yeah we'll continue to see who builds
momentum this show was produced by the
world's greatest production B team Erik
Mao so did the show design
Tammy Hyatt is the IT adviser Jonathan
Krantz is our floor manager Isaac Krantz
is graphics and sound danny Machuca is
our technical director and right here at
the desk international master of Italian
Emer name er pardon me yeah I'm Ben
Simon and until tomorrow at 3:30 p.m.
right here on US chess chat champs calm
we say so long from the Show Me State
thank you
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you